[Music]
hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things are considered I'm Peter Lavelle
turkey is at a crossroads how does it
defend its security and sovereignty
while remaining a member in good
standing in the NATO military alliance
is it true Ankara must choose between
Washington and Moscow and is turkey a
force for good in the Middle East
[Music]
Krauss [ __ ] turkey I'm joined by Miss
Omer odds Keys LLL check in Ankara he is
a security analyst from the set to
Foundation a Turkish think-tank in
Montana we have Paul volley he is a US
Army retired Major General as well as
the chairman of stand-up America US
Foundation and in India we cross his
family Johnny he is an international
affairs editor of the Hindi daily as
well as author of the Isis Caliphate
from Syria to the doorsteps of India
all right gentlemen crosstalk rules in
effect that means you can jump in any
time you want I always appreciate Amir
let me go to you first in Ankara because
turkey is the subject of so much Western
media speculation I think a lot of it is
very misinformed and actually quite
prejudiced turkey actually is a
sovereign country and should be able to
make sovereign decisions that's kind of
left to miss by many people in the
Beltway or commonly known as the swamp
so when we look at the the s400 s
arriving from Russia obviously the Trump
administration is not happy about that
and sanctions are looming here how do
you how how do you personally like if
you could speak how maybe the Turkish
government sees all this going on
because the the sanctions act you know
the count countering America's address
adversaries through sanctions act is
good to be used and Turkey is a NATO
member that's being treated as an
adversary explain that to us go ahead
and Ankara okay great so first of all
let me start with this point that from
Turkish perspective there is a huge
security need because we have a more
environment I want to okay we have a
catastrophic situation in Syria in Iraq
and we have Iran just next door so
photog it's quite important to have an a
defense system in in the hands and to be
able to defend the Turkish people from
any attacks
so therefore Turkey was in a research
and search for air defense system and
actually took you wanted to by the
American patriots air defense systems
but somehow it couldn't be done as the
US side was not ready to sell to okay
these air defense systems so over the
process of the years we got to a point
that took a now
appreciates the Russian s400 air defense
systems and actually will use it in the
coming months to deafen Turkish airspace
so here I think it's quite important to
an assent that this is an defence system
and its main goal is to protect the
Turkish people with the basic goal and
ambition and think the government has to
do but about cuts I act and to sanctions
by the years
first of all these sanctions are not
against an adversary but to prevent at
the u.s. at Versailles which is Russia
to grow and expand and increase its
military operations including military
arms sales so Turkey is being sanctioned
not because it's an MSA of two years but
because it's buying these different
systems from the from Russia which is we
have a time delay so let me go to Paul
right now we have a time delay with
Ankara
Paul how do you see all of this because
I mean did bring up a good point is that
they wanted to buy the Patriots and the
Americans said no and then even Donald
Trump was always kind of a mystery to
all these things even publicly said that
what we we weren't allowed to sell them
our missiles when they bought them from
another country Russia which I I guess
is considered an adversary and all this
Russia is just selling its hardware
around the world just like the United
States go ahead in Montana well I think
Peter you have to look at this with a
little bit of common sense first of all
the point you made Turkey is a sovereign
nation and as a sovereign nation they
can purchase any kind of military
equipment from anybody in the world just
like Russia could or United States if we
needed something to add to you know the
equipment that we have for example so I
think in this situation you have Turkey
going ahead with that because again they
have the
to have a missile defense system just
like has been mentioned here by our
guest from Istanbul so I think you've
got some politics being played you have
some people perhaps in the US State
Department and even the Defense
Department that may be trying to impose
that restriction of sanctions that
President Trump will make or not make so
I think from the standpoint of Turkey
having that it's important but you know
turkeys sort of plays by sitting on the
fence with NATO and Russia be served in
a very various position there and I
think from that standpoint you know
they've got to look at Russia to their
north and then they have to look and see
what part they play in NATO and and many
obviously even president Trump is not
sure the mission anymore for NATO and
it's been very expensive and the United
States is you know funded most of most
of the NATO funding for several decades
well since world war ii actually in a
NATO when it was formed so I think
they'll work it out I would not advise
president Trump to have sanctions let
Turkey buy what they need and they may
buy 100 f-35 stealth fighters so from
the United States if they're allowed
okay if they are allowed Stanley let me
go to you I mean we we talked about the
politics of all of this but you know
when you when you look at the NATO
countries where do they get most of
their hardware from the United States
okay they old they want one arms
supplier okay they don't want anyone to
crowd out the market I mean this is just
crass and they you know and the spin
they put on it is just grotesque here
they think that have the the
military-industrial complex wants its
pound of flesh okay and it doesn't want
to compromise that's what this is all
about here okay and the Russians are
making getting a foothold into the
market oh my goodness the world is
coming apart really it's this it's just
this practical and tread and transparent
go ahead Stanley
turkey is a NATO country historically
traditionally Network countries bought
their advanced weapons from the United
States so now Russia is now cutting into
this market that is one thing that is
the strategic significance of Turkey and
NATO member buying s400 one of the most
advanced if not the most advanced
missile system from Russia see Russia
thought the whole point of NATO which is
which is polar our institution the whole
point of NATO right now and the
post-soviet world is to check Russia so
the irony is in a sense Turkey is buying
s400 from Russia so a NATO member
despite objections from both NATO and
the United States so I think this is
more than the military-industrial
complex the argument is very significant
so besides the military-industrial
complex are given this that
geopolitically I think this is kind of
you know this introduces cracks and the
post to Soviet Atlantic come senses so
which was which was in play and there
was an Atlanta consensus between the
between between the Atlantic countries
including Turkey in the in the NATO
alliance so in that alliance Russia is
now entering balance which is you know
the the changing geopolitical realities
those realities are also helping these
this change in the policy of enthalpy I
think the United States and also okay
let's go back to Ankara Amir I mean the
way the mainstream media presents it in
their and mainstream media is simply
awful on foreign policy it's just simply
dreadful okay but I mean they're
pitching this kind of artificial
dichotomy anchor it must go with
Washington or it must go with Moscow how
do you feel about that being in Turkey
right now is it such an either/or
question go ahead so first of all it's
not an either/or
and Turkey is a NATO partner will remain
a NATO partner but this does not mean
that Turkey can not build as a
partnership with Russia and cooperate
with Russia so there's an important
aspect here turkey is still involved in
NATO's deterrence policies against
Russia but on the other side it's also
cooperating to Russia because turkey
believes that we now live in a new world
a system in which it's important to have
more communication more negotiation more
cooperation and more partnership with
various actors so we don't have a one
polar world from the eyes of the Turkish
government anymore in the world and
secondly about the arms pushes by Fergie
I don't think that this is a question
about the market but this is a political
question because there's also French
Italian and Chinese air defense systems
but it was Russia who was willing to
sell Turkey these air defense systems
and I think the main question we have to
ask here is what has the Americans done
wrong
that NATO partners such as turkey which
is highly committed to the NATO alliance
head to pushes as 400 defense systems
from Russia and I think here the two
important aspects played a huge role
first of all Syria and DVS support to
the YPG tails organization and secondly
we had yesterday the 3rd anywhere say of
the coop attempt in which the Western
States and the Western media have proven
to be
untrustful ok let's go to Paul because I
marry an anchor is extremely diplomatic
and I do give him credit for that but he
didn't emerge some very very important
contentious issues 40 seconds to you
Paul before we go to the break go ahead
well certainly Turkey is looking at this
situation through their eyes and the
United States is looking at it through
their eyes and then you have Russia
providing the s400 the missile defense
system and I think it does come down to
commercial buy and they tried to mix
Peter the politics into it which totally
confuses things and create these false
scenarios at times but again if you go
back to the reality of it turkey has a
right to buy anything they want anywhere
anytime just like the the rest of the
countries do and I think just being a
defensive system it's not going to throw
any kind of threats or any kind of guest
creating a scenario where Turkey would
be against the United States and not
siding with NATO in certain situations I
need to jump in here gentlemen we're
gonna go to a hard break and after that
break we'll continue our discussion on
Turkey State with our team welcome back
to crosstalk where all things are
considered I'm Peter LaValle to remind
you were discussing Turkey
[Music]
okay let's go back to Stanley in India I
want to continue with this either or you
know the turkey has to turn to
Washington or Moscow here with the
caveat here I think it's really
important first of all I think NATO
should be dissolved completely it is
obsolete it has no purpose to exist it
just wastes money and creates artificial
security threats
having said that Turkey is a regional
superpower and it's flexing its muscles
that's perfectly normal
I mean before the Cold War turkeys
behavior would consider considered
normal by any diplomat in States person
okay but because of the Cold War the
turkey is treated differently it's
always treated differently and Turkey
has options it has political capital and
it has reach okay
I think Turkey makes a lot of mistakes
but it is a sovereign state in sovereign
states have I guess in a sense the right
to make mistakes all right so I think
that's that's what's really happening
here it's the evolution of the of the
Middle East Western powers have
mismanaged thoroughly mismanagement for
a century turkey is stepping up it
doesn't mean I agree with everything it
does because we're gonna talk about
Syria
go ahead Stanley and in in India is a
very important point the evolution of
the Middle East because to understand
where he is now I think we have to look
at two factors one was it's the
evolution of its relationship with the
United States I am NOT predicting that
Turkey will exit NATO or ties with the
United States would be completely that's
not the point but you know the United
States against the Soviet Union it was a
buffer actually between the Atlantic
powers and Soviet Union used to be a
launch pad for the Iraq invasion and
then there was the 2016 attempt was
there
so turkey wants to be it which is also
not happening and more importantly Syria
so you know turkey initially that along
the United States or he wants the United
States to interfere in Syria and
so in 2015 almost you know reality
itself
okay well Stanley I'll have to stop you
there Russia is not interfering it's
being asked into the Middle East okay
it's being invited into the Middle East
it was invited into Syria let me go to
Paul because we've finished really short
with you in the first half - I mean
Syria is a very interesting case because
and that's where the US and Turkey
really have major differences here both
countries are in Syria their unwanted
there they're there illegally under
international law and they're on the
opposite side of an issue here and the
Syrian government backed by Russia
invited by Russia is a player that can
is able to talk to more and more
countries and leaders in the Middle East
the u.s. less and less so
and I think it's up to Turkey to make
some really key decisions because it's
such an important country and I think
it's its entire intervention in Syria
has been an unmitigated disaster for
Turkey and its political leadership go
ahead Paul Peter I'm one of the few
senior officials retired army that
actually has gone into Syria I went in
twice into Syria in 2012 during the
initial opposition force against the
Assad regime I went in with 400 men went
to Aleppo so I have a fairly good
understanding what was happening from
2012 on to today but Turkey of course
they did not back Assad they've got the
Kurdish situation which is very
important to Turkey the United States
you know we put special operation forces
and some other assets into Syria to
defeat Isis along with the actions taken
by Russia in Syria so you know as that
plays out now Isis is basically
destroyed completely and they're
recording their their influence in other
areas of the world especially in Africa
and to some degree in Afghanistan so
that has to be much very carefully but
you know turkeys in a very tenuous
situation who do they support who they
don't who do they consider threats to
Turkey and as was pointed out the
Russian plane that was shot down by
supposedly invading and going into a
Turkish airspace that created a problem
at that time and I think President Putin
was the very patient in that and didn't
launch any kind of a attack before that
so it continues to be a situation in the
Middle East that may go on for years and
years and years we don't know but
certainly it is more at rest now in that
area and what it was when I went in in
okay well mirror let me go back to
Ankara here I mean we there'll be a lot
of quibbling and finger-pointing over
the s for hundreds but Syria is a
totally different thing because the
United States and Turkey are completely
at
they're both unwanted they're both
they're illegally and you know this is
what's the the the biggest difference
between the two countries now having
said all that I understand turkeys
security concerns on the border with
Syria I get that and I think that's
actually legitimate okay
but the withdrawal of troops from a glib
and the air to Guan government is
promised repeatedly to remove them and
very slowly I mean they're in a tough
tough space and it's all because of
miscalculation on the part of the
Turkish government how do you solve that
because nobody likes you there including
the illegal troops that the United
States has there how do you resolve this
go ahead so great but I have to fix some
of your statements first of all about
the illegal statement we had there's an
official Russian statement which
indicates the quite opposite of what you
said secondly extra sure about the ad
lib observation points of Turkey which
was agreed in Astana a process secondly
it's about Assad regime itself as you
know turkey does not view the sat with
him as the legitimate government of
Syria but the Syrian government okay
talking point these are just ridiculous
what is Turkey going to do it's
catastrophic situation in Syria go ahead
let me let me explain explain if you
want me to answer you have to let me
speak so we can argue here a lot about
who is illegal and who has committed
more crimes so we don't need to speak
about the Russian several crimes in
Syria how they bombed hospitals et sera
but here about the Turkish position the
touch position is quite clear Tokyo does
not want a new refugee flow towards its
borders therefore the Turkish presence
and Italy is crucial because we have
seen that any ceasefire agreement zone
was been escalated and the deed was
broken by Russian tourists are to regime
only in it left not it is still at the
escalation zone and only because of the
Turkish army presence there so there are
some disagreements by I think both sides
can
overcome these issues and about the ease
of the oil phase where the ypg tale
organization has been present so
actually I am personal advocating near
that Turkey has to take unitary military
actions and has to wipe out its border
region from tears elements and about
Syria's future here it's clear the
Turkish position turkey wants a
political transition in line with the
Geneva process in line with the Astana
process which was also agreed by Russia
and Iran and the western states and
total ones have elected favorable new
what about what about a sovereign Syria
in Syria Syria can you answer that
question what about a sovereign state
come to this point they know they come
don't tell me about your filibustering
hands in the scary question I will try
it yes yes I would actually come to this
answer to the question if you not
interrupted me again
so photogate the main goal in the Syrian
politics is the territorial integrity of
Syria
why are you occupying their country then
if you want sovereignty let me come to
this point because because yes if Tokyo
wasn't inside Syria we would not have
Syria anymore okay you would have
controlled a region you have to destroy
the village to save them right into the
village to save it right is that your
logic we have well go to Paul Paul give
you the last minute of the program go
ahead well we've got a lot of work to do
all of us all these countries that are
involved with Syria in the Middle East
and we've got to look to the future
I developed a plan for the
rehabilitation a renaissance plan for
rebuilding Assyria and I gave
to President Trump and I also provided
my friend Mikkel Bogdanoff the foreign
ministry and Russia that plant and
that's what we have to look forward to
Peter how do we rebuild yet all the
countries out of there we need a new
government in in Syria there's no doubt
about that
Assad does not have the support of all
the people but a very small part of the
population so we have to look to a new
free and democratic Caesarea and that
has to be done by the people of Syria
okay well you know over the last few
years trying to export democracy to
Syria's been an absolute catastrophe
absolutely and so many outsiders fueling
a war that never should have happened in
the first place shame on all of them and
you know who I'm talking about let the
people of Syria decide their future
that's all the time we have gentlemen I
want to thank my guests in Ankara
Montana and in India and thanks to our
viewers for watching us here at RT see
you next time and remember Rostock rules
you